the Reagan coalition was based on an
alliance between on the one hand small
government you know big business
conservatives on the one hand and the
kind of cultural resentments especially
among white working-class Americans on
the other they held those together it
was a very reliable way for the
Republican Party to retain national
power
I think that's come unglued it's come
unglued for a variety of reasons 2008
being one of them the Republicans had
not much to offer their working-class
you know followers except what more tax
cuts you know cut Social Security I mean
Donald Trump understood that that was
one of the reasons I he was able to come
in and take the part take the nomination
for himself he understood the class
aspects of all of this in a way that the
Republican establishment just did not
and they were coming forward through all
the old bromides right and he came along
and said no no no ya the tax issues but
we can even compromise them the tax
stuff minimum wage maybe not such a bad
idea but free trade free trade free
trade I'm gonna be the man who can make
the deals now that is not the typical
Republican establishment or even a
typical Republican line so he was able
to he was able to move to the left if
you will so he's on the left of the
Republican Party he's more like Bernie
Sanders in many ways on some issues than
he is like the Republican Party at the
same time he's doing all the you know
the xenophobia the racism all of that so
where is the the center to all of that I
don't know which is really what makes in
my thinkin this is where the Clinton
people have to be very concerned it
makes them a very unpredictable
candidate it makes them very difficult
to gauge you kind of knew what you were
getting with certainly if Jeb Bush had
gotten the nomination or if Ted Cruz had
gone the nomination two very different
people you kind of knew what what what
was there with Trump who changed
position that he held at nine o'clock in
the morning with great you know great
fervor you can change it all by four
o'clock in the afternoon I mean this
makes it we're not dealing in a
fact-based universe here we're dealing
in reality television it's something
that we that no political consultant I
think is quite figured out if he becomes
president will he be able to do
everything that he says he's going to do
no we do have still have a constitution
suspends the Constitution as you know it
you might imagine some some some fantasy
right we were under great attack or
something and he suspends the
Constitution well then we have a crisis
that we've never faced the country
before except possibly in the case of of
secession in 1860 61 where you know that
was over that was a constitutional
crisis that ended up with 750 thousand
military dead I don't want to go through
that again can trump do whatever he
wants as president can he become a
dictator only by suspending the
Constitution the United States under the
Constitution mean that I say to her
plenty to check plenty of checks and
balances on him not as much as you might
like though within the military you know
he is commander in chief so it would be
a crisis presidency yeah every time you
get one of these movements and there's
been again they've occurred before in
American history
there's always an argument that somehow
somebody has taken America away from
Americans and we're going to try to
bring it back take it back from them and
restore what was that happened with the
Federalists in 1800 about the natural
unnatural eyes dimma grants had happened
in the 1850s with Irish immigrants and
you know Catholic immigrants and German
Catholic and Irish and German Catholic
immigrants and it's happening now
something terrible has been taken away
and they're trying to bring it back it's
appealing to people's fears that are
appealing appealing to people's sense of
appealing to people's sense that they
are no longer they don't over count he's
peeling to people's sense of there's
their resentments and grievances but
we've seen that before as well I mean
this isn't there's nothing new about any
of this interestingly it's usually a
sign or it's been a sign of a political
party that's about to crack up and that
certainly happened in 1800 it happened
in the 1850s in 1920s and 30s the the
old guard and the Republican Party that
brought back the economics that led to
the Great Depression they too were being
buoyed up by a resurgence of nativism
which led to a law in 1924 that grossly
destroyed restricted immigration from
abroad in all three cases the parties
either collapsed entirely or they were
marginalized the Republicans didn't
elect a president from Franklin Delano
about coming in in 1932 until 30 years
later and the really the the president
they elected in 1952 Dwight Eisenhower
basically ratified a New Deal consensus
so so this this greater making America
great again usually means that a party's
about to get get under you know fall
under great pressure it's gonna do if
not collapse and tired Elysee is going
to disintegrate or be pushed to the
margins